well portland took that the second
time out perhaps to get david oh
beautiful pass put it down
[Applause]
it is good at a foul i'll tell you what
mark
cantor hasn't had a great game but he's
got
six offensive rebounds and they have
been timely
there's they swing it anthony
rebound canter pops it out
covington yes robert
covington we are rotating early with the
double teams to lillard
and it's giving kenner an opportunity to
attack the offensive glass against the
guard is bam able to knock down that
jump
nice move but canter is there for the
putback
[Applause]
nice pass for adebayo flips it up today
remaining in the fourth
mccollum gets it down low it counts and
the foul
derrick jones jr with the bucket
iguodala will throw in
for adebayo spins and makes it home
22 it's in lillard's hands lillard steps
back
and fires comes up short but you heard
the whistle with
one second remaining lillard
will go to the line
[Applause]
blazers set up carefully and it was
willard
with the ball in his hands from straight
away
there's the step back and the foul
and little a superb free-throw shoot of
five for five here
three-point lead no time-outs they're
going to have to fling it down
court and obayo
gets it broken up by lillard the buzzing
sounds
and that will do it
the portland trailblazers defeat
the miami heat 124